after years in development and
controversies Galore The Flash is
finally sprinting into theaters with way
more characters and way more Batman than
even the rumor mill expected here are
the details in the big game trailer and
TV spot that may have run right past you
The Flash trailer features appearances
from bat Fleck and Michael Keaton as
their respective iterations of The Dark
Knight which will undoubtedly please
fans of the Snyder verse and Tim
Burton's Batman that said while it's
exciting to see these fine actors back
in Action their trailer cameos only
confirm returns we've known about for
months but are they the only Batman in
the trailer as of this video it is
unknown if Robert Pattinson and
Christian Bale will return as Batman in
The Flash the rumors have been rampant
for months but the trailer may have lent
some meat to speculation 11 seconds into
the teaser there is a shot of Gotham's
resonant hero soaring down the streets
on his Fat Cycle this part is
interesting as this reading question is
located in Glasgow Scotland both the
Batman and The Dark Knight Rises use the
Scottish City for some of their
respective Gotham City sequences to be
more specific George square is the
Glasgow location featured in the trailer
this street just so happened to be used
in the Batman sure using the same
location might be coincidental but let's
not rule out the possibility of Patton
Center bail making an appearance
Batman has had his share of iconic
live-action theme songs over the years
but the top of the Heap could very well
be the theme music composed by Danny
Elfman for the 1989 Batman film directed
by Tim Burton that version of the Caped
Crusader played by Michael Keaton
appears to offer help to The Flash in
his battle across alternate timelines
and just in case Keaton's distinctive
growl and cowl weren't enough the music
that accompanies his on-screen entrance
in the trailer is none other than a
rendition of that distinctive Elfman
score Keaton is featured quite
prominently in the trailer for The Flash
and it's exciting enough for fans of his
turns as Bruce Wayne and Batman and
Batman Returns to see him return once
more to the role the addition of his
theme music is just a cherry on top of
the brooding crime fighting Sunday
back in late November amid questions
about which if any of Zack Snyder's
Justice League cast members would make
the cuts of James gunns and Peter
saffron's new DC Universe rumors
circulated that the Flash Film would be
heavily edited to remove all references
to the snyderburst to avoid making
promises they didn't intend to keep for
a brief moment it appeared as though
these Cuts would mean the omission of
Ben Affleck's Batman who was previously
announced to appear thankfully it seems
that he not only made the Final Cut but
looks to be getting a pretty substantial
amount of screen time as Bruce Wayne
likely early on in the film he warns
Barry about the dangers of tampering
with time later on in the trailer we get
a good look at his brand new bat suit it
appears to be a combination of the
Snyder Justice League design and some
comic book influences most likely
inspired by the Batman hush era from
2002. the book was drawn by iconic
Batman artist Jim Lee and featured a
gray and blue costume very similar to
what Affleck's Batman can be seen
wearing in a trailer
one of the most critical aspects of the
flashpoint timeline is the altered path
the character of Superman takes while
Kell L is the big hitter of the Justice
League in the main DC continuity in the
flashpoint storyline he landed in
Metropolis he spent his entire life
living in a science lab being studied by
shadowy government entities it isn't
until the end of the story when flash
Cyborg and Thomas Wayne as Batman
discover his location and break him out
of the lab that he becomes a big part of
the climax of course with the dceu all
but dead and Henry cavill's departure as
the franchise is Superman a different
path needed to be taken this is where
Sasha Kaye comes in taking on the role
of Supergirl the trailer gives us our
first real look at the character seeing
her looking emaciated first and then
introducing herself after our two
berries break her out of the lab last
but not least we see her flying next to
the berries in an aircraft showing off
her new super suit while we know there
are some significant differences from
the comic version to the film version
including multiple Batman multiple Barry
Allen's and Supergirl there still seems
to be enough evidence of a faithful
adaptation
oh
The Flash Super Bowl trailer reveals
actions have consequences and one of the
deadliest snyderburst baddies General
Zod returns because of Barry Allen's
time traveling Antics at just over a
minute into the trailer Barry Witnesses
a transmission similar to the ones odd
broadcast while searching for Cal L and
Man of Steel the footage suggests that
the flash has returned to that same
point in time and as a result
resurrected one of Superman's greatest
adversaries or simply encountering an
alternate reality version of himself
after that the Kryptonian World engine
wreaks Havoc as it did in Man of Steel
and Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice
Mary exclaims quote I completely broke
the universe the very next shot reveals
Zod aboard a creptonian attack ship as
plumes of smoke and fire Rise From the
Ashes of a war zone below Zod says as
another Kryptonian vessel approaches
we've been waiting for you but who is he
speaking to it's unclear bazad's Attack
Force lays ways to the human soldiers
desperately trying to fight back after
two minutes in the trailer a Kryptonian
ship hovers above what appears to be the
flash clashing with either another Berry
Allen or perhaps the reverse flash and
then right after that fans are treated
to arguably the best shot of the trailer
Supergirl punches an armor-clad Zod
right in the face so did the Flash's
arrival in the past lead to Cowell's
death whatever Barry did it's now up to
the girl of steel to help stop zod's
tyranny
if you know anything about the flash
then you know that he has a sworn
Nemesis one who would do anything to
kill him and take the title to pass this
man alive for his own that's right
eobard Thon also known as the reverse
flash might be the man behind the
curtain but right now that's just a
theory known for going back in time and
killing Barry's mother Fawn is vital to
the flashpoint story and has appeared in
every adaptation of The Story So Far
including both live action and animation
alike with all that in mind it would be
surprising if this yellow and red clad
Speedster didn't make an appearance in
the upcoming movie and we may have
already seen glimpses of him besides the
brief flashes of the death of Noah Allen
that we see in the trailer there's a
strong possibility that the alternate
Berry could be the reverse flash in the
comics Thon wants everything that Barry
has and once even took over the
speedster's life in the original
Flashpoint comic Barry is reinserted
into the new timeline after he saves his
mother meaning that the inclusion of the
alternate Berry doesn't exactly make
sense given the alternate berries yellow
themed clothing this may be a nod to his
true identity as Thon lorine Berry into
a sense of false security before the
final blow he's been known to steal
people's faces before and his jealousy
toward the flash knows no bounds
of all the surprises in The Flash Super
Bowl TV spot none were more welcome than
all the Batman teases it contained
probably the most exciting is that we
got a glimpse at Michael Keaton's
different bat suits many designed
specifically for the film and another
time these might have all been made
specifically to sell a boatload of toys
but now they're just fabulous nods to
bygone eras of The Dark Knight
well there are plenty of direct
references to previous Batman comics and
uniforms such as the Neil Adams era
Batman with a blue cowl there's one that
stands out about the rest if you look
closely at the bat suit on the far left
its logo doesn't quite match the others
that's because this is actually the bat
symbol from the original Adam West
Batman series costume designer Chris
Weston confirmed this on Twitter
revealing that the nod to the 66 Batman
was completely his idea Weston explained
I was in Fanboy Heaven luckily I had a
great lead designer Alexandra Byrne who
was very receptive to my wacky Notions
along with the nod to the original
television Batman the suits holsters
which hold grappling guns rather than
twin pistols and the classic Golden Age
ears were Weston's idea as well the
longer you look at these highly detailed
uniforms the more you see the comic book
influence on them
all this focus on Bath suits is fun and
all but only true fans of The Flash
comic books will note the Insignia ring
that Barry is seen wearing throughout
the trailer in the comics Barry created
a super suit that could shrink itself
into the size of a ring that he would
wear so that he was always prepared to
save the day the suit was a sort of
friction resistant material that kept
Barry protected when running at top
speeds and even survived Barry's death
during the original crisis on infinite
first comic book miniseries on the flash
television show Grant gustin's Barry
Allen eventually gains a flash ring of
his own after years of working on
developing one and in the upcoming
feature film Ezra Miller's Barry Allen
seems to be finally doing the same thing
though he previously wore armor in
Justice League inspired by his look
during the New 52 era Barry has now
built himself a new uniform for the
flash one that's sleeker and better
matches his traditional comic book
appearance and most importantly fits
within his Splash ring though we only
get a few brief glimpses of the splash
ring at sports the hero's original
Insignia and opens at the lightning bolt
to reveal his new costume underneath
while we'll have to wait to see what the
full process looks like it's exciting to
think about this small element of The
Flash Mythos being translated to the big
screen it's about time
at this point everybody knows that the
Catalyst for Bruce Wayne's 10 years
Batman is the death of his parents
Thomas and Martha Wayne it seems as if
the death of one's parents or Mentor is
something of a requirement for DC comic
superheroes and it looks like the flash
will revolve around this idea also
bulberry is dealing with trying to save
his mother from her Grizzly fate there's
a Batman out there still mourning his
parents too so why do you want to stay
and fight to save this one
this is the world where my mom lives in
a quick moment we're shown a photograph
in Wayne Manor of a young boy with his
parents given that this photo sits in
front of the room that contains all the
bat suits it's more than likely that
this is the Wayne family as we piece
together this photo from the trailer
with the shot of Bruce entering his
secret Chambers from the TV spot this
photo may be the key to the bat cave
itself fitting given that Batman was
born the night his parents died in the
original Flashpoint story it's revealed
that the Batman of the flashpoint
timeline is actually Thomas Wayne it was
his son Bruce that was killed that night
it's not clear if that's the direction
The Flash is taking with this timeline's
Batman but Thomas still has an impact on
his fractured World here's hoping
Keaton's Batman lives up to Thomas's
comic book mantle
in the flashpoint inspired world of The
Flash Superman no longer exists after
the strange exit of Henry Cavill from
the dceu it should come as no surprise
that Superman isn't slated to appear in
the flash taking the man of Steel's
place in this reality warping story is
his cousin Cara zarell known in the
comics as Supergirl Cara has been a part
of the Superman Mythos for almost as
long as the Big Blue Boy Scout himself
showing up in various live-action
projects before this one played by Sasha
Kaye in the upcoming film Cara's
appearance is more akin to her famous
cousin's look rather than her iconic
comic book counterparts even Melissa
benoist's girl of steel from the
Supergirl television series looked more
like the car as a Rel we know from the
comics but just because this woman of
tomorrow looks a bit different doesn't
mean there isn't comic book precedent
for it after all not every Supergirl
Sports the long blonde look both the
Sorel and Laura Lane Kent versions of
Supergirl look remarkably similar to
Ko's version of the character Sorel
first appeared in Superman the 10 cent
Adventure number one and eventually
revealed herself to be Superman's lost
future daughter before being erased from
the timeline line Laura Lane Kent made
her debut in the Injustice comic series
as an imaginary daughter that Superman
might have had Justice League number 34
later reveals that in some World Lara is
real making her the version that Kaye
takes the most cues from
making their debut in the original 1989
Batman Michael Keaton's old vehicles are
also set to return in The Flash and they
look just as cool as ever Paul recent
films beginning with Christopher Nolan's
The Dark Knight trilogy have attempted
to make Batman's primary modes of
transportation a bit more realistic Tim
Burton's original Batmobile and batwing
were wonderfully impractical but
compared to some of the other Batmobiles
of late the 89 Batmobile had style and
even inspired the one from Batman the
Animated Series while Batman's flying
fox from Justice League is briefly seen
allowing Ben Affleck's Batman to catch
his prey it's Michael Keaton's batwing
that we're most excited to see take
flight the bat-shaped plane formerly
flew up against Jack Nicholson's Joker
in Batman but hasn't been seen much
since here it looks as if batwing will
serve as some sort of electrical conduit
probably to give the alternate Barry
Allen the same flash superpowers as the
original or if we're following the
flashpoint Comics here maybe it'll help
restore Barry's lost abilities long time
Batmans are no doubt already excited
about the flash but the return of the
most iconic looking members of Batman's
vehicular personal is even more reason
for excitement after all the words I'm
Batman don't mean too much if there's
nothing especially interesting behind
them
[Music]